Have you ever worked on a problem for hours or days or even weeks, turning it over in your mind until you were ready to give up finding a solution? But then the answer came to you in a flash, maybe in the shower or while you were taking a walk or doing the dishes. Many of us are fortunate enough to experience these spurts of insight at least occasionally. Aha or eureka moments have led to some of humanity's greatest achievements in science, medicine, mathematics, and art. From classic songs to life-saving cancer treatments, even to the invention of the slink, But most of the time these insights are more prosaic. Maybe a crossword puzzle answer that's eluded you for days comes to your mind in the shower
你是否曾连续数小时、数天甚至数周地研究一个问题，在脑海中反复琢磨，直到准备放弃寻找解决方案？但突然之间，答案就闪现了，也许是在洗澡时、散步时或洗碗时。我们许多人都有幸至少偶尔体验到这种灵光一现。顿悟或尤里卡时刻促成了人类在科学、医学、数学和艺术领域的一些最伟大成就。从经典歌曲到拯救生命的癌症治疗，甚至是弹簧玩具的发明，但大多数时候，这些灵感都比较平淡。也许你在淋浴时突然想起了困扰你好几天的纵横字谜答案，
or the perfect title for a paper you're writing pops into your head while you're digging a hole in the garden. Eureka moments like these are a form of creativity. They involve coming up with a new idea or a novel solution to a problem. So how does this type of creative insight differ from more analytical or methodical thinking? Where in the brain does creative insight happen?
或者你在花园里挖坑时，脑海中突然浮现出一篇正在撰写的论文的完美标题。像这样的顿悟时刻是一种创造力。它们涉及想出一个新想法或解决问题的新颖方案。那么，这种创造性顿悟与更具分析性或条理性的思维有何不同？大脑的哪个部位会产生创造性顿悟？
are some people naturally more creative thinkers than others? And how can you encourage more creativity in yourself and set yourself up to experience more of these aha moments? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. John Cunios,
是否有些人天生比其他人更具创造性思维？你又该如何激发自身的创造力，让自己体验到更多这样的顿悟时刻呢？欢迎收听“心理学对话”（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学协会的旗舰播客，主要探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我们今天的嘉宾是约翰·库尼奥斯博士（Dr. John Cunios），
a professor of psychology at Drexel University in Philadelphia. Two decades ago, his work purpose, provided some of the first evidence from brain imaging studies, that creative insight is a distinct form of thinking separate from analytical thought. Since then, he has continued to study what's happening in people's brains during moments of creativity and insight. He is also author of the book The Eureka Factor, AHA moments, Creative Insight, and the Brain. Thank you for joining us today, Dr. Kunios. Thank you. Thanks for inviting me. So a moment ago, I said that aha moments or Eureka moments are a form of creative thinking. Let's talk about that a little more. A lot of people think,
他是费城德雷塞尔大学的心理学教授。二十年前，他的研究为脑成像研究提供了首批证据，表明创造性思维是一种不同于分析性思维的独立思考形式。从那时起，他继续研究人们在创造力和顿悟时刻大脑中发生的事情。他也是《尤里卡效应：顿悟、创造性思维与大脑》（The Eureka Factor: AHA Moments, Creative Insight, and the Brain）一书的作者。欢迎做客我们的节目，库尼奥斯博士。谢谢。谢谢邀请我。那么刚才我提到，顿悟时刻或尤里卡时刻是一种创造性思维。我们再多谈谈这一点。很多人认为，
think of creativity more in terms of things like musical or artistic ability. What makes an aha moment a type of creativity? Okay, well, let's first start with what creativity is. Creativity is not just in the arts. Creativity occurs in science. Creativity occurs in everyday life, in all aspects of life. So probably the most common definition is that for something to be creative, it involves coming up with an idea or a product that is both novel and useful. I'm not crazy about that definition. It seems to be as close to a standard definition as we have at this point. So for something to be novel, obviously has to be novel for the individual. So if I have never read Shakespeare's Hamlet, but I sit down and I write Hamlet, then it's novel to me. It's not novel to the world,
人们更多地从音乐或艺术能力等方面来理解创造力。是什么让顿悟时刻成为一种创造力？好的，那我们先从什么是创造力开始。创造力不仅存在于艺术中。创造力发生在科学中，发生在日常生活中，在生活的方方面面都会发生。所以，最普遍的定义可能就是，要让某事物具有创造力，它就必须包含一个既新颖又有用的想法或产物。我其实不太喜欢这个定义。不过它似乎是我们目前能找到的最接近标准定义的说法了。因此，要让某事物具有新颖性，显然它必须对个人而言是新颖的。所以，如果我从未读过莎士比亚的《哈姆雷特》，但我坐下来写出了《哈姆雷特》，那么对我来说它就是新颖的。这对世界来说并不新颖，
but at least it's novel to me. It would be very creative if I could do that, not having read Shakespeare's Hamlet. Useful? That's a little bit harder. Useful to whom? Certainly there are, for example, brilliant theorems that have been proven in mathematics that at the time were of no use to anyone. And perhaps 100 years later, theoretical physicists used it to come up with a novel understanding of, say, particle physics or string theory or whatever. So something could be useful at one time and not be useful anymore later. So that's not a great definition either. Maybe a little bit better is to say that something is appropriate. So you could come up with an idea that is new to you. And it may not be right. Perhaps it's a brilliant
但至少对我来说是新颖的。如果我在没有读过莎士比亚《哈姆雷特》的情况下能做到这一点，那将是非常有创造力的。有用吗？这就有点难了。对谁有用？当然，例如，数学中已经证明了一些出色的定理，但在当时对任何人都没有用。也许一百年后，理论物理学家用它来对粒子物理学、弦理论或诸如此类的东西有了新颖的理解。所以某事物可能在某个时期有用，而在后来就没用了。所以这也不是一个很好的定义。或许稍微好一点的说法是，某事物是“恰当的”。所以你可以想出一个对你来说是新的想法。而且它可能并不正确。也许这是一个精彩的
failure. I mean, we all have had brilliant failures. They were creative, but they just didn't pan out. But at least they were appropriate to a particular problem or question or of some interest. So novel and useful, novel and appropriate. That's one way of thinking creativity. Another approach, which I like a little better, is that creativity is the ability to take the elements of thought and break them down and reorganize them into something that is. new. So, for example, you could take the notes of the musical scale and rearrange those to come up with a beautiful melody. You could take words, rearrange those to come up with a poem. You could take the elements of mathematical equations, rearrange those to come up with a new theorem, a new equation.
失败。我的意思是，我们所有人都经历过精彩的失败。它们很有创造力，只是没有成功。但至少它们适用于特定的问题或问题，或者具有某种吸引力。所以新颖且有用，新颖且恰当。这是思考创造力的一种方式。另一种我更喜欢的做法是，创造力是这样一种能力：把思维的各个要素拆解开来，并将它们重新组合成某种
So I kind of like that. It gets away from the useful part. I mean, it still has to have something appropriate to it. So, for example, if you have someone who has schizophrenia, they may be reorganizing all of their associations in novel ways. But those could be kind of random. They're not really, we wouldn't call it creative, because it could be just gibberish. If it has some purpose, some appropriateness, then we can still call that creativity. Yet another possible way to think of creativity is the ability to think on your feet. So this is what cognitive psychologists call fluid intelligence.
新的东西。所以，例如，你可以把音阶的音符拿来重新排列，创作出一段美妙的旋律。你可以拿单词重新排列，写出一首诗。你可以拿数学方程的要素重新排列，想出一个新定理、新方程。所以我挺喜欢这种说法的。它避开了“有用”这个部分。我的意思是，它仍然需要具备某些恰当性。所以，例如，如果你有一个患有精神分裂症的人，他们可能会以新颖的方式重新组合他们所有的联想。但这些可能是相当随机的。它们并不是真正的——我们不会称之为创造力，因为它们可能只是胡言乱语。如果它有一定的目的、一定的恰当性，那么我们仍然可以称之为创造力。思考创造力的另一种可能方式是随机应变的能力。这就是认知心理学家所说的流体智力。
So it's your ability to deal with novel situations where you can't rely that much on past experience. You have to improvise. Think on your feet. That would be one potential form of creativity. And as we can talk about later from our studies of musical improvisation, it's creativity can be different for people who are novices in a particular field versus being experts in that field. So those are just, you know, different ways of defining creativity, and you can apply that
所以这是你处理新情况的能力，在这些情况下你不能过多依赖过去的经验。你必须即兴发挥，随机应变。这可能是创造力的一种潜在形式。正如我们稍后可以讨论的，从我们对音乐即兴创作的研究来看，对于特定领域的初学者与该领域的专家来说，创造力是不同的。所以这些只是定义创造力的不同方式，你可以将它应用到
to all areas of life, whether it's arts, the humanities, science, practical aspects of daily life, you know, trying to get a toddler to eat vegetables. You might come up with some great idea to do that. Those are all forms of creativity. So how do you study this? I mean, you use neuroimaging to look at what's happening in people's brains when they're having insights, but you can't necessarily predict when an insight will happen. So how do you measure when someone is having an actual eureka moment? Okay. So these eureka moments or aha moments, they're one form of creativity. So one way to look at this is that since it's difficult to come up with a definition, of creativity that everyone agrees on. The approach that I've mostly taken in my research is to take
生活的各个领域，无论是艺术、人文、科学、日常生活的实用方面，比如试图让幼儿吃蔬菜。你可能会想出一些好主意来做到这一点。这些都是创造力的形式。那么你是如何研究这个的呢？我的意思是，你使用神经成像技术来观察人们在产生灵感时大脑中发生了什么，但你并不一定能预测灵感何时会发生。那么，你如何衡量某人何时真正经历了尤里卡时刻呢？好的。所以这些尤里卡时刻或顿悟时刻，它们是创造力的一种形式。因此，看待这个问题的一种方法是，既然很难提出一个每个人都赞同的关于创造力的定义，
some phenomenon that everyone agrees is a manifestation of creativity. And these aha moments or eureka moments, researchers seem to have a consensus that those are one manifestation of creativity. So we can focus on that. Now, the famous eureka moments, you know, could be Isaac Newton with the apple falling in gravity or. or Paul McCartney having a dream of which gave him the melody for the song yesterday, all of these things. You know, these are kind of rare events. We can't chase people around, predict when they're going to have an aha moment or
我在研究中主要采取的方法是，选取一个每个人都同意是创造力表现的现象。而这些顿悟时刻或尤里卡时刻，研究人员似乎达成了一种共识，即它们是创造力的表现之一。所以我们可以专注于这一点。现在，那些著名的尤里卡时刻，你知道的，可能是艾萨克·牛顿看到苹果落地而发现重力，或者是保罗·麦卡特尼做了一个梦，梦中给了他歌曲《昨天》的旋律，所有这些事情。你知道的，这些都是比较罕见的事件。我们不能跟在人们屁股后面，预测他们什么时候会产生顿悟，或者
as psychological scientists call them an insight, and then stuff them in a brain scanner and wait for it to happen. We just can't do that. And neuroimaging also requires not just a single instance of an aha moment. it requires multiple instances. We have to average over many of these things in order to extract the brain activity that's associated with Yohama. So my colleague and collaborator longstanding Mark Beeman, who's at Northwestern University, who also co-authored the book, The Eureka Factor with me. Many years ago, we decided to take a different approach. And that is, instead of waiting
正如心理学科学家所称的那样——顿悟，然后把他们塞进脑部扫描仪里等着它发生。我们就是做不到。而且神经成像不仅需要单一的顿悟实例，它需要多个实例。我们必须对许多这类事情进行平均，以便提取与顿悟相关的脑活动。因此，我的长期同事和合作者马克·比曼（Mark Beeman），他来自西北大学，他也与我合著了《尤里卡效应》这本书。很多年前，我们决定采取一种不同的方法。那就是，与其等待
for these insights to come, we would use little verbal puzzles that a person could solve in a few seconds. And we could give people many of these. So the analogy might be that biomedical researchers studying a disease, trying to come up with a cure for disease. They use a, say, a mouse model. And the mouse model is in many respects, I mean, mice are not humans, but they've been engineered genetically to have certain characteristics that would allow us to predict based on how a mouse responds to things, whether this drug, for example, might be helpful for humans. So we're sort of using a mouse model in a way. We use these little problems, which we have every reason to believe differ from the big Eureka
这些灵感的到来，不如我们使用一些小型的文字谜题，一个人可以在几秒钟内解开。我们可以给人们提供很多这样的谜题。所以这个比喻可能是，研究一种疾病的生物医学研究人员，试图寻找治愈这种疾病的方法。他们使用，比方说，小鼠模型。在许多方面，小鼠模型——我的意思是人类不是小鼠，但它们经过基因工程改造，具有某些特征，使我们能够根据小鼠对事物的反应来预测这种药物是否对人类有用。所以我们在某种程度上使用了一个小鼠模型。我们使用这些小问题，我们有充分的理由相信，这些小问题与大型尤里卡
moments only in their size or scope. We can give people many of these little puzzles and study the brain activity when people solve little puzzles that either with a flesh of insight or solve them analytically. So we've selected types of puzzles such as anagrams or other types called compound remote associates. These are little puzzles that a person can solve in one of two ways. They can solve it, say you have an anagram. One way to solve the anagram is you consciously, deliberately, methodically, rearrange the letters to find a word. We would call that analytical thinking. That goes back, that term goes back over 100 years. In other ways, you look at the anagram, and then after a second or two, the solution just pops into your awareness. It could take longer than a second
时刻的区别仅在于其规模或范围。我们可以给人们提供许多这样的小谜题，并研究人们在解决这些小谜题时的大脑活动，无论是通过灵光一现还是通过分析来解决。因此，我们选择了一些类型的谜题，例如变位词或另一种称为复合远距离联想的谜题。这些是人们可以通过两种方式之一解决的小谜题。他们可以解决它，假设你有一个变位词。解决变位词的一种方法是有意识地、刻意地、有条不紊地重新排列字母以找到一个词。我们称之为分析性思维。这个术语可以追溯到一百多年前。另一种方式是，你看着变位词，然后过了一秒或两秒，解决方案就会突然进入你的意识中。这可能需要一秒钟以上
or two. You have your aha moment that gives you the word. That would be insight or an aha moment. So by giving people lots of these puzzles, and for each one that they saw, we asked them, did that just pop into your head or did that result from sort of working it out in a conscious, deliberate way? We can sort the solutions into aha moment solutions and analytic solutions and compare the brain activity for the two of these. And we can look at, you know, what are the brain areas that you are uniquely activated when a person solves the problem with a sudden insight versus solving it analytically. So you've found evidence that some people tend more toward analytical thinking and more
或两秒。你有了顿悟时刻，从而得到了这个词。这就叫顿悟或顿悟时刻。因此，通过给人们提供大量这样的谜题，并且对于他们看到的每一个谜题，我们都问他们，这个词是突然浮现在脑海里，还是通过某种有意识的、深思熟虑的方式琢磨出来的？我们可以将解决方案分为顿悟时刻的解决方案和分析性的解决方案，并比较这两种情况的大脑活动。我们可以观察，当一个人通过突然的顿悟解决问题与通过分析解决问题时，哪些脑区会被独特地激活。所以你们发现证据表明，有些人更倾向于分析性思维，而另一些人则更倾向于
toward insightful thinking. But what are the actual differences between the two and do most people tend more strongly in one direction than the other? So, yes. So actually, let me back up a little bit. So what we found in our initial study, which we published in Plos biology in 2004, was that for a particular type of verbal puzzle. The inside itself, the aha moment itself,
倾向于顿悟式思维。但是这二者之间的实际区别是什么？大多数人更倾向于某一个方向，还是没有明显倾向？是的。事实上，让我稍微倒回一点。我们在2004年发表在《PLOS生物学》杂志上的初步研究中发现，对于特定类型的文字谜题，
corresponds to a burst of brain activity in the right temporal lobe, just above the right ear. High frequency, EEG, and also electroencephagram, and also using functional magnetic resonance imaging, fMRI, an increase in blood flow just at the moment that the person has the solution pop into awareness.
顿悟本身，即顿悟时刻对应于右颞叶（右耳上方）的一阵脑活动爆发。高频脑电图（EEG），以及脑电图检查，同时还使用功能性磁共振成像（fMRI），在个人意识到解决方案弹出的那一刻，血流量有所增加。
So we were able to then, over a series of studies, trace backwards in time, what are the precursors that lead to a person having an aha moment? And so you're talking about individual differences between people, which are some people more likely to solve these puzzles or any kind of puzzles by insight and others more likely to solve them analytically? And the answer is yes. So in a study led in my lab by Brian Erickson, who's now a research professor at Drexel University, this was part of his doctoral dissertation research in my lab. The study was funded by the National Science Foundation. We recorded people's resting state electroencephalgae. They're resting state eGs.
因此，在一系列研究中，我们能够追溯过去，寻找导致一个人产生顿悟时刻的前兆是什么？你刚才谈到了人与人之间的个体差异，即有些人更有可能通过顿悟来解决这些谜题或任何类型的谜题，而另一些人则更有可能通过分析来解决？答案是肯定的。在我实验室由布赖恩·埃里克森（Brian Erickson）领导的一项研究中，他现在是德雷塞尔大学的研究教授，这是他在我实验室攻读博士学位研究的一部分。这项研究由美国国家科学基金会资助。我们记录了人们静息状态下的脑电图。也就是他们的静息态脑电图。
So they're sitting there, no task to perform, no idea what's going to come next. They're just sitting and relaxing. We record their brain activity. And then weeks later, we give them, in this case, anagrams to solve. And we note for each subject, you know, which ones they solved analytically and which ones they solved insightful, with an aha moment.
所以他们就坐在那里，没有要执行的任务，也不知道接下来会发生什么。他们只是坐着放松。我们记录他们的大脑活动。几周后，我们给他们提供了解谜任务，在这个例子中是变位词。我们记录每个受试者，你知道的，他们哪些是通过分析解决的，哪些是通过顿悟、通过顿悟时刻解决的。
We then divided the subjects into groups, which ones tended to solve the problems with a flesh of insight, and which ones tended to solve more problems analytically. And we compared the resting state brain. activity that we recorded weeks earlier and we found substantial differences between these two types of people. So first of all, it's amazing that recordings of resting state brain activity can predict your cognitive style in Cycle versus analytic weeks in advance, up to seven weeks in advance at least, maybe longer. We haven't determined that yet. And what we found is that
然后我们将受试者分组成不同的群体，哪些人倾向于用灵光一现来解决问题，哪些人倾向于用分析的方法解决更多问题。我们将这些结果与我们数周前记录的静息态大脑活动进行了比较，发现这两种人之间存在实质性的差异。首先，令人惊叹的是，对静息态大脑活动的记录可以在提前几周甚至长达七周（至少如此，也许更久，我们尚未确定）的时间里，预测你的认知风格是倾向于顿悟还是分析。而我们发现的是，
the analytical thinkers in their resting state tend to have more brain activity over the frontal lobe. We could record over the frontal lobes. And the insightful thinkers tend to have more resting state brain activity in left posterior parts of the brain. So the frontal lobe is the seed of what we call executive processing, cognitive control. It gives us focus. It sets goals. It focuses a tension, when the frontal lobe is more deactivated, it's less active, then thinking becomes sort of fuzzier, less goal-directed, less organized, and people who have less frontal lobe activity, at least on average, tend to have more of these aha-mooms, these sudden insides. And that's sort of why people tend to have these aha moments when they're, say, in the shower, you know, taking
分析型思考者在静息状态下，额叶部位会有更多的脑活动。我们可以通过额叶进行记录。而顿悟型思考者在左脑后部倾向于有更多的静息态脑活动。因此，额叶是我们所谓的执行加工和认知控制的发源地。它赋予我们专注力。它设定目标。它集中注意力。当额叶变得不那么活跃时，思维就会变得有些模糊、较少以目标为导向、较少组织性。而额叶活动较少的人，至少平均而言，往往会有更多这种顿悟时刻，即突然的灵感。这就是为什么人们往往会在例如洗澡的时候，洗一个
a nice warm shower. They're relaxed. It feels good. They don't have anything else to do at the moment. Their minds wander, you know, and they get relaxed and in that fuzzy state, then they can have a homoids. But if, you know, you have a couple of cups of coffee, you have a test to perform, you're maybe have a deadline, you're very focused, that boosts analytical thinking. And you tend to work things out in a more, more methodical, deliberate way. So yes, so there are analytical thinkers, there are insightful thinkers on average. I mean, virtually all of the subjects we've tested, and we've tested hundreds of subjects over the years. Virtually all of them solve some puzzles with insight and some puzzles analytically. There's no one who's, you know, never has an
舒适的温水澡时，产生这些顿悟时刻。他们很放松。感觉很好。他们当下没有什么别的事要做。他们的思想在漫游，你知道的，他们放松下来，处于那种模糊的状态中，然后他们就会有顿悟时刻。但是，如果你喝了几杯咖啡，你要参加一个测试，你可能面临截止日期，你非常专注，这会促进分析性思维。你往往会以一种更具条理性、更深思熟虑的方式来解决问题。所以，是的，平均而言，既有分析型思考者，也有顿悟型思考者。我的意思是，实际上我们测试过的所有受试者——这些年来我们测试了数百名受试者——几乎所有人都是通过顿悟解决一些谜题，也通过分析解决一些谜题。没有谁是从来没有过
ha moment that we've found and no one who never thinks analytically. I mean, it's just that some people tend to be balanced more one way or the other. And you can sort of nudge people one way or the other in various ways and we can we can talk about that too. That really resonates. I'm a great fan of the New York Times spelling beat, right? Which is you get seven words every morning and you have to arrange them into words and I see myself, sometimes I'm thinking analytically to come up with them. And other times I just look at all the letters, and boom, there's a word. So I get exactly what you're talking about. So let's talk about the different hemispheres of the brain. There's kind of an accepted wisdom that one side of the brain is where we do our creative thinking, the right side,
顿悟时刻的，也没有谁是从来不进行分析性思考的。我的意思是，只是有些人倾向于在某种程度上更偏向于某一边。你可以通过各种方式在某种程度上引导人们倾向于某一边，我们也可以讨论这一点。这真的引发了共鸣。我是《纽约市拼写蜜蜂》（New York Times Spelling Bee）的超级粉丝，对吧？你每天早晨会得到七个字母，你必须把它们组合成单词。我发现自己有时会用分析性思维来想出它们。而有时我只是看着所有的字母，然后轰的一下，一个词就出来了。所以我完全明白你在说什么。那么让我们谈谈大脑的不同半球。有一种普遍接受的共识，即大脑的一侧是我们进行创造性思维的地方，即右侧，
yeah, and that the left side controls are analytical abilities, such as speech, mathematics, things like that. In some sense, we're told that never the twain meet. Now, you've done some research with jazz musicians that has pretty much turned that thinking on its head to make a bad pun. What did you learn from that research about creativity and the two hemispheres of the brain? Okay. So the study that you're talking about was published last year in Neuro Image, also funded by the National Science Foundation. And it was led by David Rosen, who at the time was a graduate student in my lab. And so the topic of the hemispheres of the the brain and creativity is a very controversial topic among psychologists and neuroscientists.
是的，而左侧控制着我们的分析能力，例如语言、数学之类的事情。某种程度上，我们被告知这两者永不交集。现在，你对爵士乐音乐家做了一些研究，这几乎颠覆了这种想法——说得不恰当点。你从那项研究中关于创造力和大脑两个半球的关系学到了什么？好的。你刚才提到的那项研究去年发表在《神经影像》（NeuroImage）杂志上，同样由美国国家科学基金会资助。该研究由戴维·罗森（David Rosen）领导，他当时是我实验室的研究生。因此，大脑半球与创造力的主题是心理学家和神经科学家中一个非常具有争议的话题。
So, you know, the pop wisdom going back, oh, at least to the 1960s, is that, you know, the right hemisphere of the brain is creative. The left hemisphere is logical and analytical. And that is a leap from early studies that were done on patients who had the hemispheres of their brains separated to help inhibit epileptic seizures. Right. So surgically separated. Yeah.
所以，你知道的，至少可以追溯到20世纪60年代的流行智慧是，你知道的，大脑右半球是创造性的。左半球是合乎逻辑和分析性的。这是一个巨大的跨越，它基于早期对大脑半球被分离以帮助抑制癫痫发作的患者所做的研究。没错。所以是通过手术分离的。是的。
Surgically separated. And it was quite a leap. But the idea infused the pop culture. And we talk about right brain thinkers and left brain thinkers. So neuroscientists correctly say that, you know, the normal brain is not cut in half. the two hemispheres of the brain work together. They work together almost all the time. So it can't be that the right hemisphere is the creative hemisphere and the left hemisphere is the analytical hemisphere.
通过手术分离的。这是一个相当大的跨越。但这个观点渗透到了流行文化中。我们谈论右脑思考者和左脑思考者。因此，神经科学家正确地指出，正常的大脑并没有被切成两半，大脑的两个半球是一起工作的。它们几乎所有时间都在一起工作。所以绝不可能是右半球是创造性半球，而左半球是分析性半球。
It can't be. The whole brain's involved. Well, that's going a bit far too. Because what the research has shown, in our case with our studies of particular types of these puzzles, is that the aha moment, the brain activity at the moment of insight is a burst of activity in the right temporal lobe. And, you know, that's the right hemisphere. It's kind of suggestive right there. There's something going on.
这不可能。整个大脑都参与其中。嗯，这也说得有点过头了。因为研究已经表明，就我们对这些特定类型谜题的研究而言，顿悟时刻、产生灵感瞬间的大脑活动是右颞叶的一阵活动爆发。而且，你知道的，那是右半球。这本身就很有暗示性。这里面确实有些门道。
Work that my colleague Mark Beeman and his longtime collaborator, Ed Bowdo, have done behavioral work and mostly. And also research that presents information directly to one hemisphere. of the brain or the other suggests that the right hemisphere of the brain processes what we call remote associations. So for example, if I say the word water, you might think of the word glass. That's a word that comes to mind immediately, because those are close associations.
我的同事马克·比曼（Mark Beeman）和他的长期合作者埃德·鲍登（Ed Bowden）做过行为学研究，主要是行为研究。此外，将信息直接呈现给大脑某一半球或另一半球的研究表明，大脑右半球处理我们所谓的远距离联想。例如，如果我说“水”这个词，你可能会想到“玻璃杯”这个词。这是一个脑海中立刻浮现的词，因为这些是密切的联想。
You think of a glass of water. If I were to say the word water, and then you came up with the word table, right? like water table, that is a remote association. It's not the first thing that comes to most people's minds. Bowden and Beeman's research suggests that these remote associations tend to be stored in the right hemisphere of the brain, and that the left hemisphere of the brain processes close association.
你会想到一杯水。如果我说“水”这个词，然后你想到了“桌子”这个词，对吧？比如“地下水（water table）”，这是一个远距离联想。这不是大多数人脑海中首先浮现的词。鲍登和比曼的研究表明，这些远距离联想往往储存在大脑右半球，而大脑左半球则处理密切的联想。
So if I say water and you say glass, that's left hemisphere. If I say water and you say table, that's right hemisphere. And the right hemisphere is necessary for, for example, understanding the gist, understanding humor, understanding things that are not like face value straightforward. And that work still holds up and there's something to it. But we can take that a step further. So there's what we found in our study of jazz improvisation. We measured people's EEGs while they improvised on the guitar, jazz.
所以如果我说水，你说玻璃杯，那是左半球。如果我说水，你说桌子，那是右半球。右半球对于理解主旨、理解幽默、理解那些不仅仅是字面意思的事情是必不可少的。这项研究依然站得住脚，而且它确实有一定道理。但我们可以将此推进一步。我们在爵士乐即兴创作的研究中发现了这一点。我们在人们即兴演奏吉他（爵士乐）时测量了他们的脑电图。
And some of these musicians were experts who had been performing jazz gigs for decades and decades. They were really good at it. Others were novices, and they hadn't been doing it very long. And then we had people who were in between. So we looked at, for each subject, we looked at their, they did a series of improvisations, and we had experts later on rate the creativity of each improvisation, not knowing who actually performed. So we looked at the best versus the worst improvisations for each subject, in terms of most creative versus least creative.
其中一些音乐家是几十年来一直在进行爵士乐演出的专家。他们真的很擅长。其他人则是新手，他们从事这项活动的时间不长。然后我们还有处于中间水平的人。因此，我们观察了每个受试者的表现，他们做了一系列即兴创作，后来我们请专家对每次即兴创作的创造力进行了评分，而这些专家并不知道实际表演的人是谁。所以我们从每个受试者的最佳与最差即兴创作中进行了观察，就最具创造力与最不具创造力而言。
And what we found is that experts improvisations, their best versus their worst, activated the left posterior parts of the brain. for the novices, their best versus their worst, activated the right hemisphere, mostly right frontal areas of the brain. We found this surprising. So looking around in the literature, there's kind of an old theory of the hemispheres in creativity that was first proposed by a neuropsychologist named Elkonen Goldberg.
我们发现的是，专家的即兴创作，他们的最佳与最差表现，激活了大脑的左后部。而对于新手来说，他们的最佳与最差表现激活了右半球，主要是大脑的右额叶区域。我们觉得这很令人惊讶。因此，查阅相关文献后，关于创造力中大脑半球的作用，有一种古老的理论，最初由一位名叫埃尔科恩·戈德堡（Elkonon Goldberg）的神经心理学家提出。
And what he argued is that the right hemisphere processes novel, stimuli, novel experiences. When there's something new for you, a new task, a new stimulus, it's the right hemisphere that's engaged. As you become more and more practiced at it, as it becomes more and more familiar, that activity moves to the left hemisphere. So, for example, in most people, the left hemisphere is dominant for language because adults are so practiced at language.
他认为，右半球处理新颖的刺激、新颖的体验。当你遇到新事物、新任务、新刺激时，参与其中的就是右半球。随着你对它越来越熟练，它变得越来越熟悉，这种活动就会转移到左半球。例如，在大多数人中，左半球在语言方面占主导地位，因为成年人对语言非常熟练。
it moves from the left to the right. So what this looks like, in our case with our jazz musicians, is that for the novices, improvisation is still not that familiar for them. It's a still kind of a new experience. And when they have to improvise, they improvise in our study to set chord and rhythm sequences that we gave them. This was sort of an unfamiliar task. So they work it out, you know, deliberately, analytically, if you will. They're consciously strategizing. Right, I'll do this. Now we'll do that.
它从左边转移到了右边。所以，在我们的爵士乐音乐家案例中，情况看起来是这样的：对新手来说，即兴创作对他们来说还不是很熟悉。这仍然是一种相当新的体验。当他们不得不进行即兴创作时，在我们的研究中，他们是根据我们给他们的固定和弦和节奏序列进行即兴创作的。这可以说是一个不熟悉的任务。所以他们会努力摸索，如果你愿意的话，他们会有意识地、分析性地解决它。他们在有意识地制定策略。对，我这就这么做。现在我们这么做。
That didn't sound so good. Now we'll try this. That worked better. Okay. The experts don't do that. The experts, if they've been doing this long enough, and they really have been, many of them did it for decades and decades,
那个听起来不太好。现在我们试试这个。那个效果更好。好了。专家不这么做。专家，如果他们做的时间够久，而且他们确实做了很久，许多人已经做了几十年又几十年，
they just sort of turn it on. And it's like a faucet. And it just flows. It just flows. And so the novices are using more of this, think on your feet type of creativity. But as the years of practice go by, it shifts to the left hemisphere. And it becomes more, just turn it on, it's automatic, it flows. You don't have to think about it. And that may relate to this idea, this older idea, it's not that old, of beaming and
他们就会自然而然地开启这个状态。就像水龙头一样。它就这样流淌出来。它就这样流淌。所以新手使用的是这种“随机应变”类型的创造力。但随着练习年限的推移，它会转移到左半球。并且变得更加自动化，只要一开启就能流淌出来。你甚至不需要去思考它。这可能与这种观点有关，这种较旧的观点——其实也不是那么旧，是比曼
and embowed and that I've worked on also, of remote association. So in the right hemisphere, So when you get something that's new, it's remote. It's a remote association. You don't think of that normally. So if I were to say water table, water table, it might be a new idea for you. But if you start thinking and reading about water tables a lot, it might move from the right hemisphere to the left hemisphere, eventually, because it becomes practiced. So this might be a way of thinking about the hemispheres and creativity. It may be that it's not sort of creative in the right hemisphere versus uncreative in the left hemisphere.
和鲍登的观点，也是我曾参与研究的远距离联想观点。所以在右半球中，当你遇到新事物时，它是遥远的。这是一个远距离联想。你通常不会那样想。所以如果我说地下水（water table），地下水，这可能对你来说是一个新想法。但如果你开始大量思考和阅读有关地下水的内容，它最终可能会从右半球转移到左半球，因为它变得熟练了。所以这可能是思考大脑半球与创造力的一种方式。可能并不是右半球具有创造力而左半球没有创造力。
What it may be and what the newest data suggests is that the right hemisphere, and especially the right frontal lobe, is especially good at and very important for creativity in terms of thinking on your feet, dealing with a novel situation, something that's unfamiliar. It might be what intelligence researchers call fluid intelligence, whereas the left hemisphere is more of the focused on this practiced creativity. It would practice in that particular genre or test, say musical improvisation, could be other things. It gets baked in. It becomes more effortless. You don't, a lot of it becomes unconscious. The music just flows and goes right to your hands as you're performing. So that is sort of our latest way of thinking about creativity in the brain. And so in a sense, the right hemisphere, according to this idea, is the seat of one form of creativity. And that is this ability to deal with novelty, whereas the left hemisphere is this ability to take from baked in experience, longstanding experience, and process the information unconsciously, and then it just flows. It kind of speaks to the idea of the creative geniuses in human history, like you mentioned, Isaac Newton and the falling apple,
真实情况以及最新数据表明的是，右半球，尤其是右额叶，在随机应变、应对新奇情况、不熟悉的事情方面特别擅长且非常重要。这可能就是智力研究人员所说的流体智力，而左半球则更多地集中在熟练的创造力上。在那个特定流派或测试（比如音乐即兴创作或其他事情）中的练习已经根深蒂固。它变得更加轻松自如。你不需要……很多事情都变成了无意识的。当你表演时，音乐自然流淌，直接流经你的双手。所以这可以说是我们对大脑中创造力的最新思考方式。因此从某种意义上说，根据这种观点，右半球是一种创造力形式的发源地，即处理新奇事物的能力，而左半球则是从根深蒂固的经验、长期经验中汲取信息并无意识地处理信息的能力，然后它自然流淌。这某种程度上印证了人类历史上的那些天才，就像你提到的，艾萨克·牛顿和落下的苹果，
Thomas Edison and the electric light, for example. And there's some thinking that these insights arise spontaneously, and yet if you look more closely at the lives of some of these people, they've actually spent hundreds of hours working at their craft or their science before they reach these achievements. I'm just wondering how much of genius, as we call it, consists of aha moments and how much is only possible because of the obsessive focus on a particular specialty,
托马斯·Edison和电灯等等。有一种观点认为，这些灵感是自发出现的，然而，如果你仔细观察其中一些人的生活，他们实际上在取得这些成就之前，已经花了数百个小时在他们的手艺或科学上。我只是想知道，我们所谓的天才，有多少是由顿悟时刻组成的，又有多少仅仅是因为对某个特定专业（无论是音乐、科学、绘画，还是你痴迷的任何东西）的执着专注才得以实现的？这取决于你想在哪方面具有创造力。每个人都是某种领域的专家。我的意思是，每个人都是日常生活方面的专家。没有人比你更了解你的日常生活。既然你是日常生活方面的专家，你就很有条件去拥有关于如何在日常生活中做事情的顿悟时刻。并不是每个人都有条件去对粒子物理学产生顿悟。我的意思是，这需要多年的学习。它需要大量的
whether it's music or science or painting, whatever it is that you're obsessed with. It depends on what you want to be creative about. So everyone is an expert at something. I mean, everyone is an expert at daily life. Nobody knows your daily life better than you do. So since you're an expert of daily life, you're in a position to have these aha moments about how to do things in your daily life. Not everyone is in a position to have aha moments about particle physics. I mean, that takes years of study. It takes a lot of
分析能力来理解其中涉及的数学和实验。因此，如果你想在粒子物理学方面有创造力，你就必须做你的家庭作业，数年又数年的家庭作业，然后你才有条件产生这些惊人的灵感。你需要沉浸和练习来获得专门的知识，但不一定需要沉浸在一个特定的问题或难题中。例如，你知道的，一个众所周知的观点是，你有一个问题或难题，然后你可能会在稍后产生顿悟，无论你是在洗澡时，还是在夜里醒来时，诸如此类。但在某些情况下，人们会产生一个顿悟，给他们一个答案或想法。
analytical ability to understand the mathematics and the experimentation involved. So if you want to be creative of particle physics, you've got to do your homework, years and years of homework, and then you'll be in a position to have these amazing insights. You need the immersion and the practice to gain the specialized knowledge, but you don't necessarily need to have immersion in a particular question or problem. So, for example, you know, it's well known the idea that, you know, you have a question or a problem, and you might have an aha moment later on, whether you're in the shower or it wakes you up during the night or something like that. But there are instances where people have an aha moment that gives them a solution or an idea.
这就像是解决了一个他们甚至不知道自己面临的问题。我非常喜欢的一个例子是，1943年，在海军的一艘美国海军舰艇上，有一位名叫理查德·詹姆斯（Richard James）的工程师。他的工作是安装弹簧作为减震器，用来缓冲仪器，这样当海浪汹涌、舰艇颠簸时，仪器就能保持稳定。当时船上有各种仪表之类的东西。所以他在安装弹簧，然后其中一个弹簧松脱了，开始像有生命似地到处跳跃。他看着那个场景。他想，哇，这会是一个很棒的玩具。经过一番开发，它就变成了弹簧玩具（Slinky）。当时他在考虑玩具吗？
It's like a solution to a problem they didn't even know they had. So one example that I really love of this is that there was this engineer aboard a Navy ship, U.S. Navy ship in 1943, his name was Richard James. And his job was to install springs to, like shock absorbers, to cushion instruments so that when there was a rough sea and the ship was being buffeted about, the instruments would be stabilized. There were like gauges and things like that. So he's installing the springs, and then one of the springs got loose and started bouncing around like it had a life of its own. So he looked at that. He thought, wow, this would make a great toy. And after some development, it became the slinky. Now, was he thinking about toys before that?
我对此表示怀疑。没有证据表明这一点。他只是看到了这个场景。这激发了他脑海中的一个想法。这并不像他一直在酝酿或长时间地与这个问题作斗争。这只是一个绝妙的主意，解决了连他自己都不知道自己存在的问题。所以，你知道的，再次说明，顿悟、创造力可以自发产生。它不必由某个问题触发。它完全可能就这么发生了。而这正是创造力最神奇的地方之一——它的自发性，以及它偶尔是刻意搏斗于某个问题或目标之产物的特性。人们可以做些什么来鼓励这种创造性顿悟？
I doubt it. There's no evidence of that. It just, he saw this. It sparked this idea in his head. And it wasn't as if he had been sort of incubating or struggling with this problem for a long time. it was just a great idea that was a solution to a problem he didn't know he had. And so, you know, again, so insight, creativity can be spontaneous. It doesn't have to be triggered by a problem. It could just happen. And that's one of the amazing things about creativity is that the spontaneity of it, as well as it being the product occasionally of, you know, deliberate grappling with a problem or a goal. What can people do to encourage this kind of creative insight?
我的意思是，我们能做些什么来在生活中引发更多的顿悟时刻吗？因为我想我们都希望能更有创造力。是的。确实有，而且这是一项正在进行中的研究。有些研究已经很成熟，有些正在涌现，还有些研究的各个方面，在几年后我们才会完全确定。但让我们从我们所知的基本原理开始。所以，心理学中有一个原则，即心理安全感。你可以感到安全和没有威胁，也可以感到受到威胁和焦虑。例如，
I mean, are there things that we can do that will spark more aha moments in our lives? Because I think we'd all like to be more creative. Yes. So there are, and this is ongoing research. research that will be, I mean, some of it's well established, some is emerging, others will, other aspects of it will, in a number of years, we'll know for sure. But let's start with sort of the basics of what we know. So there is a principle in psychological, psychological safety. You can feel safe and unthreatened or you can feel threatened and anxious. So for example,
假设你是生活在非洲大草原上早期人类，你看到远处有一只狮子，在那一刻你会变得非常专注和焦虑，因为如果那只狮子发现了你，你就完蛋了，对吧？所以你会呆立原地，专注于这只狮子。你会想，好吧，狮子发现我了吗？我能做些什么来避免被发现？我在狮子的上风向还是下风向？我会发出声音吗？如果我逃跑，狮子会看到动静吗？你会非常小心。
when say you're an early human on the savannah in Africa and you see a lion way off in the distance at that moment you're going to become very focused and anxious because if that lion detects you, you're finished, right? So you're going to freeze, you're going to focus on the line. You're going to think, all right, has the line detected me? What can I do to avoid being detected? Am I upwind or downwind of the lion? Am I going to make noise? If I run away, will the lion see the motion? You're going to be really careful.
这就是分析性思维。它是深思熟虑的，是专注的，是非常有条理的，因为你承担不起犯错的代价。另一方面，你仍然是那个早期人类。你晚上和你的族人待在山洞里。你们都吃饱了。你们都很安全。
That is analytical thinking. It's deliberate. It's focused. It's very organized because you can't afford to make a mistake. On the other hand, you're still that early human. You're in your cave at night with your clan. You're all well-fed. You're all safe.
你感到放松。当你放松时，就没有威胁。没有威胁时，你的注意力就会扩展。没有风险。思考疯狂的想法是没有风险的。探索那些离奇的想法是没有风险的。这与面对狮子的情境非常不同，因为在面对狮子的情境中，你不能犯错。
You feel relaxed. When you're relaxed, there's no threat. When there's no threat, your attention expands. There's no risk. There's no risk to thinking crazy thoughts. There's no risk to exploring, you know, off-the-wall ideas. And it's very different from the lion situation, because in the lion's situation, you can't make a mistake.
你必须非常小心。你不能去尝试各种可能性。所以，许多研究人员长期进行的研究告诉我们，积极的心情可以增强创造力。当你处于积极的情绪中时，你会有一种心理安全感。你的注意力会扩展。你会变得不那么自我批判。但是当你感到焦虑时——这种焦虑可能由很多事情引起，可能是对尴尬的恐惧，可能是截止日期，可能是很多事情。
You have to be really careful. You can't try things out. So what we know from longstanding research by many researchers is that creativity is enhanced by a positive mood. When you're in a positive mood, you have this feeling of psychological safety. Your attention expands. You become less self-critical. But when you're anxious, and that anxiety could be caused by a lot of things, it could be fear of embarrassment, it could be a deadline, it could be a lot of things.
你会变得更具分析性。你会以非常谨慎的方式做事。而且分析性思维仍然可以产生有创意的产品。例如，如果你接到一个任务，要你想出一些点子，并且要求它们都必须是有创意的，你可能会——而且你只有大约10分钟的时间来完成它——那个截止日期可能会让你集中注意力并变得非常分析化。但你可能会在意识上拒绝所有没有创意的想法。所以你呈现出来的将是你思维中最好、最有创意的部分，对吧？你进行了筛选，你用你分析性、专注的思维来过滤自己。
You become more analytical. You do things in a very careful way. And analytical thinking can still result in a creative product. So, for example, if I give you a task to come up with a number of ideas and say they all have to be creative, you'll probably, and you have like 10 minutes to do it, you'll probably, that deadline will make you focus and be very analytical. but you'll probably consciously reject all of the non-creative ideas. So what you present will be the best, the most creative of your thinking, right? You filter, you use your analytical-focused thinking to filter yourself out.
所以，总的来说，积极的情绪会增强顿悟性思维，而焦虑以及它引起的任何事情都会导致更多的分析性思维。而且这一点，你也可以将其延伸到“扩展注意力”的概念上。例如，如果一个人处于一个开阔的环境中，他们走到户外，或者身处一个挑高很高的大房间里，所谓的“感知注意力”与“概念注意力”之间存在着某种联系。这两者是相互联系的。当你的注意力扩展到填满一个巨大的空间时，
So, but in general, positive mood enhances insightful thinking, anxiety, and anything it causes focus will result in more analytical thinking. And this also, you can extend this to this idea of expanding attention. So, for example, if a person is in an expansive environment, they go outside or they're in a big room with high ceilings, there's a link between what's called perceptual attention and conceptual attention. The two are linked. When your attention expands to fill a large space.
所以，但总的来说，积极的情绪会增强洞察性思维，而焦虑以及任何引起专注的事情都会带来更多的分析性思维。你也可以将这一点延伸到扩展注意力的概念上。例如，如果一个人处于一个开阔的环境中，他们走到户外，或者身处一个高挑的大房间里，所谓的知觉注意力与概念注意力之间存在着一种联系。这两者是联系在一起的。当你的注意力扩展以填满一个巨大的空间时。
That expansion of perceptual attention also expands conceptual attention. So that's why a lot of creative figures, they like to take walks in nature. Or even in the shower, you know, there's white noise. Your vision is kind of blurred. You can't sense the, it's a hot shower. You can't sense the boundary between what's outside of your skin and what's inside. You kind of feel almost disembodied. and that allows your attention to expand, and you can get these crazy, wonderful ideas.
感知注意力的扩展也会带来概念注意力的扩展。这就是为什么许多创意人士喜欢在自然中散步。甚至在淋浴时，你知道，有白噪音。你的视线有点模糊。你感觉不到，那是热水澡。你感觉不到皮肤外侧和内侧之间的界限。你几乎觉得自己快要脱离肉体了，这让你的注意力得以扩展，你能涌现出这些疯狂而美妙的想法。
But if you're in a cubicle and you're guzzling coffee and you've got something due in an hour, your attention will narrow and focus and become analytic. So you can sort of jumpstart this expansion of attention by being in wide open spaces and avoiding things that grab your attention. It could be striking works of art. It could be anything that grabs your attention, bright colors, that will narrow your focus. So being in sort of fuzzy, warm environments,
但如果你坐在格子间里，狂喝咖啡，一个小时后就有截止日期，你的注意力就会缩小、聚焦并变得具有分析性。因此，通过身处开阔的空间并避开那些吸引你注意力的事物，你可以启动注意力的这种扩展。这可能是引人注目的艺术品。这可能是任何吸引你注意力的东西，鲜艳的颜色，那会缩小你的焦点。因此，身处某种朦胧、温暖的环境中，
kind of new agey, all of that, attention expands, and it expands the scope of thought. Another thing is working, doing your creative work, when your thinking is a little fuzzy. So some people are morning people, some people are evening people. You do your best analytical thinking at your peak time, whether it's morning or evening or afternoon. You're more likely to think in sort of an insightful creative way during your off-peak hours when you're thinking is a little fuzzy and not so analytical.
有点新纪元风格之类的，所有这些，注意力都会扩展，并且它扩大了思维的范围。另一件事是进行工作，进行你的创造性工作，当你的思维有点模糊的时候。所以有些人是早起型，有些人是夜猫子。你在你的巅峰时间进行最佳的分析性思考，无论是早晨、晚上还是下午。在你思维有些模糊、不够分析化的非巅峰时间里，你更有可能以一种富有洞察力的创造性方式思考。
Also, and I'm not recommending that people drink alcohol, I mean, because there are health repercussions, But there's plenty of research now that shows that an alcoholic beverage, you know, we're talking just in moderation. It makes you're thinking a little fuzzy, and you can start making these connections that are harder to make if you're more focused and analytical. Probably one of the most powerful ways to jumpstart creativity is sleep. And for three reasons. One, if you sleep, then it puts you in a better mood. If you're sleep deprived, you're cranky, you don't feel good. But if you get enough sleep, you're in a positive mood, and that helps creativity.
此外，我并不是建议人们喝酒，我是说，因为有健康影响，但现在有大量的研究表明，一杯含酒精饮料，你知道，我们只是说适量。它会使你的思维变得有点模糊，如果你更专注和分析，你就开始建立那些更难建立的联系。激发创造力最有力的方法之一可能是睡眠。出于三个原因。第一，如果你睡觉，那么它会让你心情更好。如果你睡眠不足，你会暴躁，感觉不好。但如果你获得充足的睡眠，你就会拥有积极的情绪，这有助于创造力。
Sleep also helps with what's called fixation forgetting. A lot of creativity is blocked because you're focused on a bad idea or bad ideas or non-creative ideas. When you sleep, and this is the reason why breaks help. If you're stuck on something, you take a break, you do fixation forgetting. It flushes. You forget the wrong idea that you're stuck on. Sleep supercharges fixation forgetting and flushes out bad ideas so you can start with more like a blank slate and come up with creative ideas. Sleep also promotes what's called memory consolidation.
睡眠还有助于所谓的“定势遗忘”。许多创造力被阻碍，是因为你专注于一个坏主意、一些坏主意或非创意的点子。当你睡觉时，这也是休息有帮助的原因。如果你在某个问题上卡住了，你休息一下，你就会进行定势遗忘。它会冲洗掉。你忘记了让你陷入困境的错误主意。睡眠能增强定势遗忘，并冲刷掉坏点子，这样你就可以像一张白纸一样重新开始，并想出创造性的点子。睡眠还能促进所谓的记忆巩固。
So the information you take in during the day while you sleep, it becomes consolidated in the brain. And part of that is a reorganization of the knowledge. the information, that reorganization can bring out non-obvious ideas, non-obvious features, which is why a lot of people have, they get ideas, sometimes they wake up in the middle of the night with an idea, or the idea presents itself in the morning just as you wake up and you're not fully there yet. And for example, Paul McCartney got the melody for the song yesterday in his sleep. He woke up, there it was, he wrote it down, He didn't even know if this melody was something he had come up with or something he'd heard somewhere else.
因此，你白天吸收的信息在睡眠时会在大脑中得到巩固。其中一部分是对知识、信息的重新组织，这种重新组织可以激发出不那么显而易见的主意、不那么显而易见的特征，这就是为什么很多人会有灵感，有时他们会在半夜醒来时带着一个点子，或者这个点子在早上你刚醒来、还没有完全清醒时就自然浮现了。例如，保罗·麦卡特尼在睡梦中得到了歌曲《Yesterday》的旋律。他醒来时，旋律就在那里，他把它写了下来，他甚至不知道这个旋律是他自己想出来的还是在其他地方听到的。
So he ran the tune by John Lennon. John Lennon said, never heard it before. It sounds great. You ran it by their manager. The manager said, never heard it before. Sounds great. So he put words to it. He said, it must have been my idea, you know?
于是他把这段曲子放给约翰·列侬听。约翰·列侬说，以前从未听过。听起来很棒。他又放给他们的经理听。经理说，从未听过。听起来很棒。于是他为它填了词。他说，这一定是我自己的主意吧，你知道吗？
And he wrote it. And it was voted as the greatest pop song of the 20th century right there. That's amazing. So sleep, even a short now. sleep can supercharge creativity. So, all right, so those are kind of, you know, that's kind of the more established signs. Looking forward, there's emerging research that suggests that electrical or magnetic
然后他把它写了下来。它当场就被评为20世纪最伟大的流行歌曲。太神奇了。所以睡眠，哪怕是一个短短的午觉。睡眠都能大大提升创造力。好吧，所以这些就是，你知道的，这些是比较成熟的科学。展望未来，有新兴的研究表明，电刺激或磁
brain stimulation may eventually be, protocols may be developed that will enhance creativity. Now, I don't think this will become a practical solution for people in general, like, you know, oh, I have to come up with an idea for an advertising campaign. Let me juice my brain with electricity. I don't think that's going to become a practical solution, but it's interesting, and there may be some very selected situations in which that might be helpful. Another possibility is using drugs to enhance creativity. You know, since the 1960s, people have been talking about psychedelic drugs.
脑刺激最终可能会被开发出相应的方案来增强创造力。现在，我认为这不会成为普通人的实用解决方案，比如说，哦，我必须为广告活动想出一个点子。让我用电流刺激一下大脑。我认为这不会成为一个实用的解决方案，但它很有趣，在某些非常特定的情况下可能会有用。另一种可能性是使用药物来增强创造力。你知道，自20世纪60年代以来，人们一直在谈论迷幻药。
for example, to enhance creativity. And there's been research. Most of it is not very rigorous. Most of it shouldn't be taken too seriously. But now, starting now, is starting to be some research that looks at the issue, the question of whether psychedelic drugs or other drugs may enhance creativity. And the jury's out. I do not recommend people use psychedelic drugs.
例如，用来增强创造力。并且已经有过相关的研究。其中大部分并不是很严谨。大部分都不应该被太当真。但现在，从现在开始，有一些研究开始关注这个问题，即迷幻药或其他药物是否能增强创造力。目前尚无定论。我不建议人们使用迷幻药。
we don't really know what the health implications will be. And we don't even know if it'll really help with creativity. It may help people to feel like they're being creative, even if it doesn't help them to actually be creative. So we don't really know at this point. But in the future, I wouldn't be surprised if there was developed a sort of a pharmacology of creativity that might even be helpful, maybe even nutrition, certain foods, chemicals in certain foods, may eventually be shown to enhance
我们真的不知道对健康会有什么影响。我们甚至不知道它是否真的能帮助提高创造力。它可能会让人觉得自己在发挥创造力，即使它并没有真正帮助他们进行创造。所以在目前我们还真的不知道。但在未来，如果有人开发出一种创造力药理学，我不会感到惊讶，它甚至可能会有所帮助，甚至营养、某些食物、某些食物中的化学物质，最终也可能被证明能增强
creativity. So that's sort of the future. And we don't really know at this point. But the general principle of positive mood, feeling safe and getting a lot of sleep, feeling good, being in an environment where your attention can expand, we know that can promote insightful. creativity and the, you know, a little bit of stress, little bit of anxiety, not too much, because, of course, if you're too stressed and, you know, you won't be thinking clearly about anything, right? But just a little bit of pressure, a little bit of stress promotes more analytical thinking. And the ideal thing, of course, is to sort of be able to alternate between these two things. You know, in an insightful frame of mind, you generate ideas, then you kind of narrow your focus
创造力。所以这就是未来。目前我们还真的不知道。但关于积极情绪、感到安全、获得充足睡眠、感觉良好、身处注意力能够扩展的环境中的一般原则，我们知道这可以促进富有洞察力的创造力，以及，你知道的，一点点压力、一点点焦虑，不要太多，因为，当然，如果你压力太大，你知道的，你对任何事情都不会有清晰的思考，对吧？但只要有一点点压力、一点点紧张，就能促进更多的分析性思考。当然，理想的做法是能够在在两件之间交替。你知道，在富有洞察力的心境中，你产生想法，然后你缩小焦点
and you edit it, you evaluate it, you can maybe tweak it, make it better, maybe you can just throw out your ideas if they're no good. And then you go back to idea generation and then back to idea analysis. That's the ideal thing. And it's not clear whether people can control or learn to control going back and forth between these two modes of thinking. Certainly a lot of people can naturally swing back and forth. And, you know, when they're in a particular frame of mind, they can do a particular type of work. When they go to another frame of mind, they can do another way of thinking, another cognitive style. But, you know, it would be great if we can develop a technique to train people to shift back and forth at will. And that would be, you know, that would be fantastic,
然后你对其进行编辑、评估，也许你可以调整它、使其变得更好，也许如果你的想法不好，你就可以直接扔掉它们。然后你回到想法生成阶段，再回到想法分析阶段。这是最理想的。目前还不清楚人们是否能够控制或学会控制在这两种思维模式之间来回切换。当然，很多人可以自然地来回切换。而且，你知道，当他们处于某种特定的心境时，他们可以做某种特定类型的工作。当他们进入另一种心境时，他们可以采用另一种思考方式、另一种认知风格。但是，你知道，如果我们能开发出一项技术，训练人们随心所欲地前后切换，那就太好了，那将是，你知道的，那将是太棒了，
but that's, I think, a ways off. I think you've offered a lot of good advice. for people to basically put ourselves in places and positions where we can have more of these aha moments. I hope our listeners have gained some insights from your insights. Thank you so much for joining us today, Dr. Kunios. Thank you. It's been a pleasure. Thank you very much for invite me. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology at www. speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. If you have comments or ideas, is for future podcasts, you can email us at Speaking of Psychology at APA.org.
但我想这还有一段距离。我认为你提出了很多好的建议，让人们基本上把自己放在可以获得更多这些“灵光一现”时刻的地方和位置。我希望我们的听众能从你的真知灼见中获得一些启发。非常感谢你今天加入我们，库尼奥斯博士。谢谢。我很荣幸。非常感谢邀请我。你可以在 www.speakingofpsychology.org 或在 Apple、Stitcher 或你获取播客的任何地方找到《Speaking of Psychology》之前的单集。如果你对未来的播客有评论或想法，你可以发电子邮件至 Speaking of Psychology at APA.org。
That's Speaking of Psychology, all one word, at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condyenne. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那是 Speaking of Psychology，所有单词连在一起，在 APA.org。《Speaking of Psychology》由李·韦纳曼制作。我们的音频剪辑师是克里斯·孔迪扬。谢谢收听。我是金·米尔斯，代表美国心理学协会。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。